have a look at the next questions you
remember I said pay close attention to
this instruction in blue okay in fact
it's the most important thing when we
get to these answers we're them down and
then we'll get to the reason what's the
size of angled why any takers
325 okay now I'm going to write y equals
325 but before that I'm actually going
to write an extra liner maybe you didn't
write this slide I'm going to ask you if
you if that was the first thing you
wrote down I'd like you to go just
before that or next to it and write this
extra line because it's kind of
important what I've got here is actually
got two angles that I'm adding together
and what's why called like the kind of
angle it's calling to see how so it goes
all the way around it starts with an R
but the killer oh very close the whole
thing is a revolution Maria
it's a reflex angle right so it's okay
we were very close unemployment
revolutions so have reflex angle and the
acute angle the shop admit they come
together to make a revolution right so
because they come together I want to
indicate that in my working so I don't
know right before this line I'm gonna
write Y plus 35 equals 360 and that's
where the next line comes from I can
take away 35 from both sides and it
stays balanced okay now there's a reason
that comes with this and we're gonna put
this in brackets next to what we put out
on our first line yeah what was the
reason that someone said and you want to
suggest like the words that they used
very good so really you're thinking
about like this whole thing gives you
360 so I'm trying to put these together
so the most succinct brief way I can say
that because you want to offer a wedding
means it's after the equals top you yeah
yeah very good so we get exactly right
on top here's the way I'm going to
weather okay I want to say the angle sum
and their angles and adding them
together so that's why he's the way the
Sun the angles son of a revolution that
was the word that you guys said to me
before which means go all the way around
the angle sum of revolution is 360
degrees okay now in fact and this is why
I put it in another color the wedding is
the most important thing about this the
reason that you provided it so much more
important than the actual number okay
because reasoning is what's special
about geometry it's how we can prove
things if we apply logical reasoning and
you can see that this reason the words
they match up to the equation do you see
that the angle sum is this left hand
side here y plus 35 X the sum and the
revolution adding up to 360 a revolution
is 360 degrees there it is right there
so if you've got some colors that love
you to a pump or a highlighter or
something like that I'd let you share
that as well how the equations that I
wrote it marrieds up it's parallel to
pursue a little bit it's parallel to the
reason that I provided okay so the
wording like I'm trying to say the same
thing from two different angles I
promise I didn't mean to say okay that
was the that was number three the first
reason number four someone want to
provide to me the answer and then we'll
get to a reason
yeah and what was the reason that came
with it
very good okay so here's the way I'm
gonna put him right corresponding angles
that's the important part because this
angle Kia and Miss Emily they're facing
in the same direction but it's not just
the corresponding angles like these
lines here you see these arrows what do
they indicate again it's true but
they're parallel if the lines were not
parallel if they were kind of wonky like
that the English would be the same there
would be anything like it's because
they're parallel so I wouldn't include
that in my races so I'm going to say
corresponding angles on parallel lines
they're equal that's why bless you this
anger this angle are the same okay now
we just point out a little thing which
is that validity and the matter why I'm
not gonna put a degree sign on them okay
can anyone suggest to me why I've left
off the degrees yeah
okay right very good suit what are they
they like just a substitution right it's
just a pretty without putting place
right it's just the number and you can
see that because when you look at these
diagrams the degree symbols already
there and there so if I had said D is
125 degrees then when I come back to my
original question I'll say oh look this
angle is 125 degrees degrees because
I've got it in twice right it's a bit
like when people say ATM machine do you
say ATM machines it's in no ATM stands
for ATM it stands for automatic teller
machine tell is like the person who pay
the money or you give money to them at
the bank so an ATM machine is an
automatic teller machine to change or a
PIN number you don't know what pain
stands for yeah it's a kind it's like a
four-digit code it's like off which
opinion right it's a it's a pin that
personally identifies you it's a
personal identification number so if I
say pin number it's a personal
identification number number so you
don't need to put an extra degree sign
in you've already gone okay